Okay, I'm going to go ahead and add these properties to this class.
This is how you do it.
You say title=db.StringProperty.
This is in the database module from Google,
and this is how you say something is a particular type.
You give your property name, and then you say equals, and then you give the type.
This is the class that represents the string type--string.
I'm going to add another parameter here--required-True.
And this sets a constraint on the database.
It means if we try to make an instance of art
without giving it a title,
we will get an exception--Python won't let us do that--
which is handy.
You want to always have as many constraints as you reasonably can
to prevent you from making silly mistakes
and putting bad data into your database.
Having bad data in your database is really annoying.
Sometimes it's really hard to find
because you don't have the appropriate keys to do your queries to look it up.
So constraints are important, and this is a handy one
that Google provides--required=True.
Let's add another field. This is our art.
This is going to be a db.TextProperty.
This will also be required=True.
Simple enough.
Actually, the first time I wrote this I used the string property,
and then I got through this whole project
and all of a sudden I couldn't paste in ASCII art longer than 500 characters.
So text is handy there.
And we're also going to add our last field for created,
which will be a DateTimeProperty.
And this takes another parameter called
autonowadd=true.
And what this property does
is it automatically--when we create an instance of art--
we'll set the created to be the current time, right now.
So we don't have to actually deal with that ourselves.
This is really handy.
Now, you may be thinking this is an awful lot to know.
You don't have to know this.
This is all in the Google Datastore docs.
So when you're working on your homework and stuff, please have those docs handy.
It will save you a lot of heartache.
There's some interesting stuff in there. This is one of them--autonowadd.
Okay, so that's all we have to do to define a type,
or at least our simple type here.
Let's go ahead and start creating these things.